foreign
Greg is going to start this hour he is
with us in Indianapolis hi Greg welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey gentlemen how are you doing better
than we deserve sir what's up in your
world
well
um my mother has just received a medical
malpractice
settlement of about a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars
my father is a degenerate gambler
uh we've been trying to explore ways
that we could uh somehow legally uh keep
this money so that it can last her for
hopefully the rest of her life and to do
it legally uh where he can't get a hold
of it and I was wondering what your
advice might be
is she still in relationship with him is
she still married
uh she is we've also explored that route
and it seems like it's it's going to
stay that way so I I don't believe that
that easiest most sensible option is
going to be an option
hmm
I'm sure Dave and I can come up with
some ideas about trusts and things like
that you're running into what I think is
one of the hardest things that we have
to deal with as finite beings which is
wanting something for somebody else
wanting healing or safety for somebody
else who for a host of reasons
does not choose that for themselves
absolutely absolutely it's power it's a
powerless feeling when you watch
somebody you love stay in a relationship
that's not safe it's powerless when you
someone gets it like this gets a a
ticket out and they choose to stay in
right it's tough tough tough tough
um yeah especially mother and father oh
gosh Polar Opposites in this situation
it's it's pretty bad even if you like
even if she Drew up a trust it
immediately gave you the money gave it
like whatever
is she going to be able to keep herself
from asking for it back or for cashing
it out and giving him a little bit here
and a little bit there
uh I think she will um she's pretty much
agreed uh that she's willing to put it
in my name along with my brother how
long is this dysfunctional relationship
going on
um well maybe forever uh I I didn't take
notice until probably about six or seven
years ago maybe
she's a completely codependent enabler
the chances of her telling him no
over the next decade are close to zero
you're correct yeah she's gonna have to
give you the money to give it away to
her kids well and then you're going to
be the evil Sean when she comes to you
and wants her money
well I mean all I'm really concerned
about is uh the legality of it I don't
want to step over the law as far as her
being him being her spouse and him
having any rights to it yeah and I also
don't want something to happen to her
and uh he gets to in his life in in that
way you know yep yep so um you would
have to speak with some attorneys in
your state are they in Indiana
yes okay you'd have to speak with some
attorneys in Indiana to get some legal
advice on how to properly do this and
what the divorce laws are in most States
Most states
from my little bit of understanding of
the law and I'm not an attorney
say that when you are married half of
what you have is his and half of a
church
and it really doesn't really matter
where you put it at that point as a
matter of fact if he if she gave it all
to you the courts might go she gave it
all to you and half of it was his
and make you give it to him in the event
of a divorce okay
um and so uh if there's if there's a
trust and she's the beneficiary of the
trust and you are the trustee
um he might have marital rights to that
trust I don't know but uh in most I'm
amazed at uh the one of the few things
would be like if um if she brought this
money into the marriage then they might
protect it but it was all they were
already married when she got the money
and in Most states the law was going to
give him access to half of it and undo
almost anything you try to do
okay the only thing that will actually
protect her is divorce
and so the problem is this
they have uh so much bigger problem
mathematically
than 125 thousand dollars
sure and uh so the the only
the best news of this is it's making her
face
this yet again in a more real way and in
a way that puts some weight on it
for her to have to actually think about
how screwed up this situation is and so
um I'm so sad for all of you it's just
heartbreaking
um but I you know meet with an estate
attorney and see if under the laws of
Indiana if there's a way you can keep
his hands off of it by moving it around
somewhere into a trust or into your name
or whatever
um I mean she can gift it to you but I
think the gift could be undone in a
divorce court in most States
have you understand
um I'm assuming that the way you talked
about your old man that this is this
ship has sailed but is there something
to be to be said for sitting down with
him and saying this is not for you this
is to keep you all alive for the next 15
years
uh this type of thing has been tried and
uh you know my dad's always kind of been
an honorable man but this has completely
uh erased all of that yeah
um
addictions turns people into liars and
manipulators
absolutely
um but being able to tell her that this
advice came straight from Dave and John
will be great okay and uh I appreciate
you guys uh telling me what you think
about it um well I'm sorry I think the
the only way I can
to my knowledge of of 30 years being in
the financial planning world to my
knowledge in Most states with the way
divorce law works as I understand it
again I want you to you're welcome to
double check the legality of this
because I could be wrong okay but I
don't think I am to my knowledge the
only way to protect this money is a
divorce and the divorce court likely
would say and you might only be
protecting half of it right it might be
protecting half of it but it might say
hey this was awarded to her recently he
has this situation but if you wait five
years they're not gonna do that that's
right okay so if you you know I think
that would protect it probably but I'm
not even sure then and Greg you have to
come to terms with the fact that you
can't want her to be well more than she
wants to be well yeah I mean you could
want it but it's not going to affect
that change and at some point you've got
to open your hands here because you're
going to put yourself in an early grave
trying to get somebody else to change
their life which you can't do she thinks
she's being
kind by going along with all this and
she's being unkind to everyone involved
herself included exactly